Just for *Pesach* I got a very interesting
shayla *Sha'ala* that I have been looking for
the opportunity to give a *Shiur* about because
I think it touches upon two very fascinating
*Sugyas*, not that it's so relevant to anyone
sitting here, but I think in *Lamdus* it
touches on two very fascinating *Sugyas*. The shaylah?
*Sha'ala* was as follows: it was a woman
from my shul who was in Eretz Yisrael
*Eretz Yisrael* for *Pesach* and her family is
among the unique group of people that ask
a *Sha'ala* about Yom Tov Sheni *Yom Tov
Sheini* to the same rabbi that they ask
all their other *Sha'alos* to. So *L'maaseh* they
were keeping two days Yom Tov *Yom Tov*
even though they were in Eretz Yisrael *Eretz
Yisrael*. So she wanted to know, since Yom
Tov *Yom Tov* fell out on Thursday and
Friday, and the first days Yom Tov *Yom
Tov* was Thursday and Friday, could she have
a bas eretz yisrael *Bas Eretz Yisrael* put
makeup on her face on Yom Tov Sheni.
*Yom Tov Sheini* on that Friday so that
she could freshen up her face? Is there
anything wrong with doing that, doing amira l'Yisrael,
*Amira l'Yisrael*, asking a Jewish person who's not
observing Yom Tov *Yom Tov* that day and
is rightfully not observing Yom Tov *Yom Tov*
that day because they're a Bas Eretz Yisrael
*Bas Eretz Yisrael*, to put makeup on her,
on her body, on her face on Yom
Tov Sheni *Yom Tov Sheini*? So really what
it touches on is two things. First of
all, is amira, *Amira l'Yisrael* mutar, *Mutar*? Are
you is a ben chutz la'aretz *Ben Chutz
la'Aretz* allowed to ask a ben eretz yisrael
*Ben Eretz Yisrael* to do melacha *Melacha* for
them on Yom Tov Sheni *Yom Tov Sheini*
while they're in Yisrael *Eretz Yisrael*? And second
of all, does it make a difference that
it's physically on her body? Does the fact
that it's on the ben chutz la'aretz *Ben
Chutz la'Aretz*'s person make a difference? So let's
start with the first question. Rav Moshe was
asked this *Sha'ala* in *Igros Moshe* Orach Chaim
*Orach Chaim* gimmel: *Cheilek Gimmel* siman *Siman Ayin
Gimmel*. You are a chutz la'aretz *Ben Chutz
la'Aretz*, you're in *Eretz Yisrael*, you're keeping Yom
Tov Sheni. *Yom Tov Sheini*, can you ask
a ben eretz yisrael. *Ben Eretz Yisrael* to
do melacha *Melacha* for you? Rav Moshe points
out that the most logical parallel to think
of in halacha *Halacha* is the halacha *Halacha*
*Psuka* in *Shulchan Aruch* Orach Chaim *Orach Chaim*
*Siman Reish Samech Gimmel* *Sif Yud Zayin* where
the *Shulchan Aruch* says, and this is very
relevant for us, Shabbos melacha *Yesh Omrim shemi
shekibel alav Shabbos kodem she'chasheicha mutar lomar l'Yisrael
chaveiro la'asos lo melacha*. If you make an
early Shabbos *Shabbos* and you're *Mkabel* Shabbos *Shabbos*
early and you realize that you forgot to
turn off the light, turn on the light,
whatever, shut the light in the fridge, and
you see that there's your neighbor who's a
frum Jew but has not been *Mkabel* Shabbos.
*Shabbos* yet because they're making late Shabbos. *Shabbos*,
you're allowed to ask them to do melacha
*Melacha* for you. There is no violation because
it may be Shabbos. *Shabbos* for you, but
it's not Shabbos *Shabbos* for them and there's
no technical issur *Issur*, there's no amira lenochri
*Amira l'nachri*, there's no violation. The Magen Avraham
*Magen Avraham* explains, but it's the real *Svara*
says *Magen Avraham* is because even for you
it didn't have to be Shabbos? *Shabbos*. You
could have chosen not to be *Mkabel* *Shabbos*.
mekabel shabbos *De-ha'ei ba'ei lo hayah mikabel shabbos
alav*. *Kol she'yesh lo heter mutar amira*. Anytime
it could have been *Mutar* for you yourself,
then there's not going to be a problem
of *Amira*. So says the *Magen Avraham*. So
one might have said this is exactly the
same case. It's Yom Tov. *Yom Tov* for
me, it's not *Yom Tov* for the other
person, so let me ask the other person
to do a melacha *Melacha* for me. Says
Rav Moshe it is not at all the
same case because you can't just decide, meaning
based on that *Magen Avraham*, the whole *Svara*
about being *Mkabel* *Shabbos* early is that you
could have decided that it's not *Shabbos* for
you. You can't decide that it's not *Yom
Tov* for you. Rav Moshe says I know
what you're thinking, yes you can, because anyone
that's in *Eretz Yisrael* could just decide to
stay. And if you decide to stay, then
it won't be Yom Tov Sheni *Yom Tov
Sheini* for you anymore, then you'll only have
to keep one day. He says come on,
you know you're not going to stay, your
kids are in school in *Chutz la'Aretz*, your
job is in *Chutz la'Aretz*, you're not going
to decide in the spot on the spot
to stay. So therefore Rav Moshe says it's
left as a *Safek*, and if it's left
as a *Safek* you have to just, meaning
we're left without any *Rayas* and without any
*Rayas* you have to assume that there's an
issur *Issur Amira*. Just like there's issur amira
l'nochri. *Issur Amira l'nachri*, there's got to be
an issur *Issur Amira*. Then Rav Moshe points
out that in fact is two *De'os* in
*Acharonim*, quoting the teshuvah *Sha'arei Teshuva* in *Siman
Tof Tzadi Vav* *Sif Katan Gimmel* where the
*Birkei Yosef* in the name of *Marikash* writes
that a *Ben Chutz la'Aretz* that's working in
*Eretz Yisrael* is allowed to tell a ben
eretz yisrael *Ben Eretz Yisrael* that to do
melacha *Melacha* for him on Yom Tov Sheini?
*Yom Tov Sheini*, and *Marei Melka* and *Marei
Prago* all disagree and say that it's not,
that it's not allowed and Rav Moshe thinks
that we should be machmir *Machmir*. In fact,
Rav Shlomo Kluger in *Chachmas Shlomo* *Siman Tof
Tzadi Vav* gives two reasons to assur. *Asser*
this, to *Asser* *Ben Chutz la'Aretz* doing *Amira
l'Yisrael* to a ben eretz yisrael *Ben Eretz
Yisrael*. Number one he says why should it
be any different than amira l'nochri *Amira l'nachri*?
amira l'nochri. *Amira l'nachri* is *Assur*, *Daber Davar*,
you're speaking in melacha *Melacha*, you're asking to
do melacha *Melacha*, it should be just like
*Amira l'nachri*. Number two he says it's worse
than *Amira l'nachri* because *Amira l'nachri* is, one
of the *Svaras* for *Amira l'nachri* *Rashi* writes
is that *Shlichus l'Akum l'chumra*. You know what?
When it comes to *Yisrael*, *Yesh Shlichus* *Mi-ikar
hadin*. Forget about *L'chumra*. They can actually be
your *Shliach*. So it's even worse than *Amira
l'nachri*. *Nafka mina* between those two *Svaras* of
Rav Shlomo Kluger whether it's the same as
*Amira l'nachri* or worse than *Amira l'nachri* is
let's say you're in a situation where you're
allowed to do *Amira l'nachri*. You're in one
of those cases where you have a *Heter*
of *Amira l'nachri*. Is it better to do
*Amira l'nachri* than *Amira l'Yisrael*? Or does it
not make a difference? So that would be
a potential *Nafka mina*. It's interesting Rav Moshe
has another teshuvah *Teshuva* in *Orach Chaim* *Cheilek
Gimmel* *Siman Ayin Aleph* where he says that
if you are an American and you have
a company or an office, a factory factory
in Israel that works, your employees are allowed
to work for you in Israel. Rav Moshe
writes in teshuvah no problem, your employees can
continue to work for you on Yom Tov
Sheini. in Israel. So then of course Rav
Moshe has a third teshuvah that says what
just happened over here it's a stira. In
one Rav Moshe says that a is not
allowed to tell a to do melacha? for
them. In a second he says well if
you have people that work for you in
yeah let them keep working for you on
So hay how can how could both be
true? So Rav Moshe writes in Chelek Daled
Siman Kuf Hey he doesn't even understand the
kasha. He says in the case where you
have an office a factory something like that
you hire people and you tell them I
want you to work on all the weekdays
so they work on every day that's a
weekday. But when you specifically ask a person
to do melacha for you on a day
that is for you that's going to be
He says mashal lema hadavar domeh let's say
a person gets lost he wanders somewhere and
he gets lost and he has no idea
what day is. So whatever day he thinks
might be he has to be and not
do anything. But people back home that work
for him that know what day is are
allowed to do melachos on days that aren't
So Rav Moshe says you're in you're not
allowed to do any melacha on but the
people in know what day is and they
are therefore allowed to do melacha on You
just can't ask them on that day to
do melacha for you. So it seems very
clear Rav Moshe. would this this that we're
talking about would be a non-starter according to
Rav Moshe. You're not allowed to ask. However
in Chelkas Yaakov in Siman Pey Hey Rav
Breisch disagrees and he says no this is
even better than the kabalas shabbos case because
the kabalas shabbos case what does the say?
That you could have decided not to make
it Yeah you could have but you didn't.
You already made it So once you made
it there's no backing out. Once you're un-mekabel
shabbos. you can't But he says with this
case you actually can decide to become a
You could still do it meaning at any
point you could decide to become a so
it's even more beyado it's even better than
the kabalas shabbos case so of course you're
allowed to ask a to do for you.
The Debreciner Rav in Beer Moshe Chelek Zayin
dinei bnei eretz yisrael vechutz la'aretz Perek Resh
Nun Ches disagrees. He says it doesn't work
that way. He says if you decide in
middle of that you're making aliyah doesn't go
away. It's it's all based on when started.
When started you were a so you're gonna
have to suffer through that even if you
decide to make aliyah right in the middle
of Happens to be in Kovetz Teshuvos Chelek
Alef Siman Nun Daled Rav Elyashiv paskens like
the Chelkas Yaakov not like Reb Moshe, Rav
Elyashiv holds that you are allowed to ask
a to do for you. He says you
should only do it if there's a real
tzorech for it a tzorech mitzvah or something
like that some sort of real tzorech for
it. So let's assume like the Chelkas Yaakov
like Rav Elyashiv is this worse? I'm not
just asking the person to do for me.
The woman is asking the Bas Eretz Yisrael
to put makeup on her face. Does that
make it worse? So the first thing that
comes to mind is the pasuk in this
past week's parsha lo takifu pe'as roshchem. The
Gemara Makos Daf Chaf Amud Beis says echad
hamakif ve'echad hanikif that there's an issur to
cut off your peyos and that's true of
both the person giving the haircut and the
person receiving the haircut. Even though the person
receiving the haircut is it's just happening on
their body they're not they're not doing anything.
Yeah they maybe if they move so then
it's called a lav she'yesh bo ma'aseh. If
they don't move it's a lav she'ein bo
ma'aseh. Either way though it's a lav even
though they're not the ones doing the action
they're the ones sitting there. Why is it
a lav? Because because it's happening on their
body. So it makes you gives the impression
that whenever an issur is done on your
body it's your issur also. It's not so
clear though that that applies to all issurim
in the Torah. The Minchas Chinuch discusses in
Mitzvah Taf Samech Zayin the issur of lo
sisgodedu that you're not supposed to cut yourself
like the real lo sisgodedu not the not
the that you're not supposed to cut yourself
in mourning over so what if someone else
cuts you in mourning over? So is that
your issur also? Minchas Chinuch says yeah because
it's said in the plural. So since it's
said belashon rabbim it probably includes the person
it's happening on also. Minchas Chinuch in Mitzvah
Reish Tzadi Alef talks about the issur of
sirus that you're not allowed to castrate an
animal or a person or anything. So Minchas
Chinuch says what if you are not the
doctor you are the patient meaning you're getting
a vasectomy? You didn't you're not the surgeon
doing the vasectomy you're just the patient lying
on the table getting the vasectomy. So is
that just an issur of is it an
of lifnei iver or is it no you're
doing the actual you're involved in the actual
because it's happening on your body? Minchas Chinuch
says he's he's not sure. What this really
boils down to this is the beauty of
it's all over the place. What it really
boils down to is a machlokes Shach and
Tas machlokes Shach and Tas Hilchos Niddah. In
Hilchos Niddah there's a machlokes Shach and Tas
Siman Kuf Tzadi Ches Yoreh Deah as follows:
That the is the Rama writes that a
woman is supposed to cut her nails before
going to the mikvah. What if she forgot
to cut her nails before going to the
mikvah and now it's ask
a nochri manicurist to cut your nails for
you because it's happening on your body, just
like lo sakifu. It's happening on your body,
you are doing the chillul Shabbos when it
happens on your body, even though the other
person is doing the maiseh. Says the Shach,
what on earth are you talking about? He
says, 'chada d'afilu chaschom bikli', well, leaving out
that one, he says, 'd'kan lo shayach mesaya
davka b'hakafa'. It's davka by hakafa by payos
that we say that echad hamakif v'echad hanikaf,
it's because it's said in the plural. But
someone does chillul Shabbos on your body, someone
writes on you, you violate kosev? Someone does
chillul Shabbos on your body, it's your meheichi
taysi? The Shach in Nekudos Hakesef rejected. How
do we paskin on that Mishnah Berurah Shin
Mem seif katan v'ishah sheshachachah litol tzipporneha m'erev
Shabbos v'chal tevilasah b'leil Shabbos, woman forgot to
cut her nails erev Shabbos and she has
to go to the mikvah on Friday night,
muskam haMagen Avraham shetomar l'oved gilulim litol beyada
mishum shvus d'shvus b'makom mitzvah v'im ee efshar
beyad mutar al yadah afilu bikli. He says
you're allowed to do He talks about the
details about maybe not using a nail clipper,
but you're allowed to do because he views
it as only He doesn't view it as
you violating the even though it's happening on
your body. So long story short, can this
woman get her makeup put on by a
on According to non-starter. No way. There's an
of you're not allowed to ask a to
do for you on But if you assume
like the Chelkas Yaakov or you assume like
Rav Elyashiv that from that perspective it would
be so then you're talya in this machlokes
Taz and the Shach. And it seems that
we paskin like the Shach, that it's not
a problem even though the is being done
on your body, it's not considered that it's
any more than an that it's not considered
that you're doing the yourself. I told her
she could do it. She ended up not
doing it. So it ended up all's well
that ends well. I think she survived without
the makeup, Baruch Hashem.